oh somebody's gonna get it she bad she's
not kidding around the cast of Wednesday
has a lot to say about the show do you
know the backstory behind Jenna Ortega's
iconic dance number or what about
Christina ricci's history with the
character Wednesday number one truly an
iconic number choreographed by Jenna
Ortega herself which is my favorite
scene we brought this up so many times
this dance has everyone on the internet
in a choke hold it's inspired so many
remakes Tick Tock videos and even Lady
Gaga had to hop onto the trend the funny
thing about this though is Jenna
wouldn't even consider herself a dancer
much less a choreographer I
choreographed that myself and I think
it's very obvious that I'm not a dancer
not one single person agrees with you
Jenna oh my God man I can I could watch
an entire show of just this did you also
catch the reference to Wednesday's
original dance number number two there
would have been a riot if we lost thing
[ __ ] doesn't mean emotional moment in
the whole show this is the only scene
where we actually see Wednesday express
some pretty intense emotions though
Jenna Ortega found it to be a bit campy
behind the scenes now it kind of campy
which I appreciate considering Jenna is
actively making a name for herself in
the horror scene she starred in the
movie X scream and the babysitter part
2. it's no surprise that this Wednesday
sequence is one of the campier horror
scenes she's shot throughout her career
[Music]
number three thing gets shocked back to
life promise that whoever did this to
you will suffer this was actually one of
the more Awkward scenes for Jenna to
shoot if you've seen our other Wednesday
videos you would know that some of the
most difficult scenes for her to get
through were the ones where she had to
hold or carry things
the reason why it was so awkward for her
was because in those types of scenes she
was usually playing pretend she didn't
always have something to hold or pick up
it's so outrageous number four everyone
loved Christina ricci's performance here
please don't make this more difficult
than maturity is Marilyn
everyone in the cast thought Christina
was the perfect person to play the
Sinister villain in the end mostly given
the fact that no one would ever suspect
her Christina with all of her
Charisma and dynamic personality the
cast actually knew the secret before
even being handed the script but
obviously had to keep it tight Under
Wraps it makes it even more of a Twist
if you think about the fact that
Christina played the OG Wednesday back
in the 90s this is my costume I'm a
homicidal maniac they look just like
everyone else pretty wild number five
we've got some Stellar acting from a
blue man under a table also Victor
killed that was that really him dude
yeah that was Victor a blue man under
the table just going as most of you
probably already know Victor dorobansu
is the magician who plays Wednesday's
severed sidekick thing that's thing
foreign like your pet most of his job
description involves hiding under beds
tables and behind Jenna Ortega while
performing a scene we can imagine just
how much his body aches after the long
work days in Romania everyone endured
filming this show Fred Armisen was
definitely feeling it that day and I was
like I just want to go home guys
come on number six Jenna Ortega knows
Wednesday would never cry over anyone
else it's also a really important moment
for Wednesday I think it's the only time
we really see her cry when talking about
Wednesday's love interests Jenna feels
strongly about Wednesday's aversion to
it I'm glad that it was over him though
I don't think it would have made it over
anything else she thinks the character
couldn't really care less about anyone
except of course for a thing I love a
slime
if you die I will kill you and
eventually Enid she was happy to see her
relationships come full circle in the
end but more on that later number seven
one of Jenna Ortega's new found skills
we've done this on my 19th birthday
I was in a storage fight like this I
would just be like you win Jenna learned
a lot of skills and worked incredibly
hard on camera as
on her days off in her spare time she
learned to fence speak German and Play
The Cello for the role there's so many
pieces of coverage and bits and also a
fencing classes
it was crucial to her that she was able
to do a lot of the physical aspects of
the show like the fencing there's really
important physical aspects like that
like the fencing that I knew that I
wanted to do myself and and have
ownership of number eight Jenna doesn't
take Wednesday's relationship slightly
Wednesday is very cold and closed off in
the beginning and you know the way that
she's always been her reaction to seeing
the end of season one was mostly in
response to Wednesday's relationships
coming full circle I think for me just
that emotional aspect was the most
satisfying or most rewarding for me
particularly the Heartbreak of losing
principal Weems and the hug she and Enid
share at the end of the big Showdown
it's clear Wednesday has changed as a
character number nine we finally get to
see Enid wolf out in the final episode
Enid who has had severe before anxiety
when it came to transforming into a
werewolf finally takes her true form to
fight the incredibly dangerous hide I
remember going into ADR and seeing our
final fight scene even when it still had
the stunt guys in that it was a highly
anticipated moment for the cast and
audience alike she was pivotal in the
success of Nevermore I texted you I was
like it's really cool
number 10 some of the actors favorite
parts of shooting were getting to watch
their co-stars act watching about a
residue this was so fun a lot of this
cast would have serious fomo if they
missed a major scene or something they
thought was really good in the script
circling back to Wednesday's dance scene
everyone really wanted to be on set that
day to watch I hadn't seen we we hadn't
seen her do this yeah I know and can we
blame them number 11. did you know you
can watch Wednesday in nearly every
language even with your eyes closed you
can still tell which character is
speaking even if you don't know the
language
Papi Gomez
there's no one more doting or concerned
than Wednesday's father and of course
you can always tell it's Wednesday by
the lack of emotional inflections
yeah I think it's me there's not enough
emotion Enid's voice is one of the most
distinct in the entire show Jenna has no
problem calling her out about it either
if it were you it'd be really obvious
yeah number 12 this is one of the first
times we see The Addams Family as part
of a regular Society we get to see
Wednesday front and center leading the
show this time with
time amazing for obvious reasons The
Adams Family has never fit in much with
the outside world because of their
notably creepy and kooky nature The
Adams Family always used to kind of
exist outside or on the periphery of
society they literally have a severed
hand as a family member we can't exactly
see things showing up for PTA meetings
or anything because of that The Adams
Family being so integrated as Wednesday
leads the narrative was one of the
cast's favorite aspects of the story so
it's fun to see them be a part of our
world especially because we've never
seen Wednesday as a teenager before only
as a child
Even after spending over eight months
filming the show the cast of Wednesday
still clearly enjoys watching their
co-stars most iconic scenes what was
your favorite moment the actors watched
any disagreements let us know down in
those comments